[Music]
i'm melina this is a show where you
bring together some fun nerds and they
offer their ideas and theories about
multiple topics we cover multiple things
you guys lately have been wondering why
we move on to other topics we do like
for three or four topics each one of
these episodes anything that's on our
minds are in that nerdy zeitgeist on
today's episode we have in roxarsone
Eric Voss oh well hello there and then
from the Godzilla vs. podcast zero
that's right we have Haley Mancini yeah
and then we skipped over just our
lifelong friend David dong
but David actually has known I think
Eric and I longer than our parents yes
well you've always existed right yeah I
mean I was I was part of the whole thing
a podcast feed it comes out way earlier
than the video version on this episode
we have some rogue theories about Thor
for it to stranger things three topics
for and more and anything with the
number in it basically we'll talk about
but first up we got to talk about it
Chapter two
yes yeah so final trailer for a chapter
two came out this week and we get a lot
more of the grownup version of the
Louise club in it it's 27 years after
the events of the film so first off like
I'm down here first reactions but I have
a very specific question I want to get
to in a second I mean I thought it was
scary it was good I was excited I guess
they get scared no I thought it was a
really well done trailer like just kind
of really putting everything together
and and Pennywise was terrifying and I'm
really excited yeah you can't ask her a
better adult cast like this yeah it
sounds like this is the Dreamcast's of
the child actors they all asked them
after the first movie so who do you want
to play the adult version of yourself
and then wolfhard was like if you could
get
bill hader that they wouldn't got just a
good testing and Bill Hader and for the
most part I like the Florida is like
storied career I did yeah and Barry I
mean who thought I'd go there so and yes
it's it's terrifying one of the most
terrifying moments for me is at the end
where we see our skarsgård actor playing
Pennywise the clown but kind of out of
makeup or semi Oh scary yeah he just is
like a dude that you'd probably see on
like Hollywood Boulevard yeah so with
that and and Pennywise and especially
this like grotesque version of them also
Joker is coming out right so I am
thinking off of this clown thing and
clowns creeping us out and I think
that's kind of a well discussed well
storied history of clowns hurting people
you study in forensic psychology report
to us the scariest clown you know mine
hunters season that's only clown sir my
question is actually adjacent to clowns
it's about carnivals what is it about
carnivals that creeped us out so much
and I'm gonna point out to you the
number of carnival scenes and creepy
carnivals we've had in the last 12
months it's insane we've had us Joker
has a scene at a carnival Shazam the
Mary Poppins movie Toy Story 4 she has a
major thing and it loves Simon which is
terrifying it's like like carnivals are
having haven't kinda like Keanu yeah
Dave but they're the carny lobby was
putting a lot of effort into this yeah
they finally they've been saving up just
a briefcase full of ticket
[Music]
they currently do not well not according
to the so going into into this thing
with Carnival so yeah I want understand
what it is about this place it's
supposed to be for joy that internally
just apparently creeps us out you know
it may be it's like a fake joy thing
because I remember as a kid like every
year our school would have a fundraising
carnival and you get really excited we
see all the lights of colors you think
of the fun weekend that you are gonna
have but then afterwards maybe this is
just me speaking once you go there it
actually becomes like this weird sadness
because you get separated from your
friends there's an odd number of your
friends you're always the one who shut
down the hall of mirrors actually have
had most of that so where's that first
joy thing and like we're gonna have so
much fun like by the end like you have a
little puking a little blood on your
right yeah you cry in front of your
friends I think it's the impermanence I
think I think yeah I think like the fact
that it's like here one day and then
gone the next like there's something
about that where it's like this whole
world gets built and then one day the
carnival is just gone like that's what I
remember when I was a kid is that you'd
see like a carnival come into town and
like you just see it there it would just
be up and you're like oh cool carnival
came to town let's go and you go do it
and then two days later you drive by and
it's just an empty field
that's crazy fascinated it's like
they're trying to cheer you if you won
this big plush bear and you're just like
it doesn't matter
I wonder if it's like connected to
living carnivals are connected to like
children's right a passage like one of
the big times out for so I think because
a lot of these movies that we touch on
are connected about kids right and like
spider-man you know in there all things
they're always about like kids sort of
being on their own
for the first time yeah I think I mean
the more noble was like a place where
that happens
yeah well and like if you look at it
through that lens then you're definitely
seeing the you know the over-the-top
imagery that exists in their child's
nightmares you know which I visit
regularly these these like stretched out
they're almost grotesque images that are
supposed to be like for joy but they're
they're too extreme a screen producer
was talking about it he was talking
about how the face of a clown is kind of
an uncanny valley right words like it's
not true what you're looking at it has
this this falseness but the entire
carnival is that right like the myth the
Hall of Mirrors
the friends that supposedly like you but
really really mean to you right it all
has this like illusion element to it but
it's also he's like stretched out more
who was that first guy that made a
stretchy mirror that like made your face
like this and was like oh this is
hilarious
yeah built a carnival around a broken
mirror factor part of it like cuz you
think a lot of the RL Stein goosebump
books were set at carnivals Stephen King
has a whole novel set at a carnival yeah
it's like every kid has a memory at a
carnival because that is the time where
your parents just let you off on your
own okay wait hold on genuine we don't
have a ton of time but real quick
carnival memories go I I threw up on my
mom's best friend but it was all sprite
she started screaming stop
that's bright mine is I all my friends
had wristbands so they could go all day
on the rides I didn't get one that's
like I'm giving you $10 i I just wore a
long sleeve jacket you know rather than
my vests that I always work and and it's
kind of random with him most of the
carnies didn't check but one time I
stood on the far end of the of the ride
and the carny just tapped my wrist and
it's kind of just like looked at me as
like I know you say did you just tap my
wrist I'm like no and you say he's back
that's my haunting memory my only memory
is I bought a giant turkey leg and I
couldn't go on any of the rides the one
time that's all I know I think mine is
the like one of the rides that was like
the one that would be a swing that would
be like a swing that you'd spin and then
all the swings would go like from a pole
like a 45 degree angle or something and
like I just like I just remember vague
like on it and being like mm-hmm
this thing is rickety this is falling
apart and also fortune tellers which is
another creepy part of it are always at
a carnival yeah but they're never with
the carnival group what did I tell you I
can't tell you really because it won't
happen is it a fortune cookie is that
what you meant by having your fortune
read I don't need to share my future
with you already said Antichrist twice
I was gonna be a doctor
well I'm being generous to myself but I
I thought yeah I was I was heavily
premed as a microbiome major and then my
mom told me at one point she was like
you know you it's so funny they were
becoming a doctor cuz years ago I went
to a fortune-teller and they told me you
would like do stuff in entertainment
instead and then I quit med school that
day you did no but I just needed it for
her to patch Adams story to I'm just
gonna point out real quick just to go
slightly back on topic with carnivals I
think about them being creepy - is that
the predecessor to carnivals were kind
of the World's Fair right new carnivals
are supposed to show you these amazing
amazing inventions but the World's Fair
is also where America got its first
serial killer first I believe it's
double in the white city no well the
first one we maybe know about yeah I
think maybe we returned one woman
earlier in the late 1700s well there's a
couple but in the States
yeah that was she would kill or like
late seventeen hundreds early 1800s and
she would have she like she was a black
widow and she would husband's what's
weird is I saw a photo and she looked
exactly like you
Wow but also I have face blindness you
guys know like a woman did that
[Music]
like the first one that I think got you
know I mean this was that was the time
with like muckraker journalism too so
there was a schism in the media yeah
kind of representative of that era and
like the swell of journalism I mean HH
Holmes was the one that like his story
was also like in a weird way the
American Dream like yeah it was
benefited from the World's Fair beam in
Chicago cuz all these like young people
and young women young couples were
moving to Chicago in that moment looking
for jobs looking for opportunities and
he set up this murder hotel he said come
stay here you can get a great deal I'll
keep you here for free and then he'd
just basically set up like weird gas
chambers trapdoors how support things
what did you expect
he's a capitalist who's an opportunity a
very ambitious man and that he viewed
himself in the Box family Empire yeah I
think suddenly it became a Halloween
episode which is fine but instead we're
celebrating another a happy event happy
birthday yeah we got a special surprise
later I've been moving on from my birth
is another nope there's no segue Thor
for guys Thor for is now or more Thor
yeah exactly
Thor ear the whole time I was like why
don't they just call it Thor and with
the for as though that's far for stick
mister fan for Stevie
so they announced this week that thor
ragnarok director Taika Waititi is
returning to direct another Thor movie
but here's what's crazy about it who
would have guessed that Thor would be
the Avenger with the most solo outings
especially based on the first two films
deep so why do we think that is why did
but is Thor have four movies and Iron
Man has three I think because those
first two were so forgettable
it's almost like Thor Ragnarok was the
reboot of it and this now Thor 4 is like
a direct sequel to Ragnarok and we're
gonna get three movies started over
named 16 things you liked about I
thought I thought it was like a good
because I didn't know much about Thor
like at the comic book character and it
didn't Kenneth Branagh he did a pretty
dang good job well he took it a kind of
brunner route exactly so I mean I
thought I was like that's cool I like
that was a cool entry point but I said
but then I mean I feel like this what
type of wood did he did is totally it's
so different that it is like its own
thing though it is like a full reboot
yes it started fresh yeah I think once
you saw like new fun 4 or newer cuz even
kind of going down that road like like
fun like like is it Thor like you you
were like I'm not done with this guy you
know like I want this new energy because
you didn't you didn't really have him
back yeah it's almost like when you
discover like a fun conversation on the
way out of a doorway or something then
you end up do anything we stand in the
doorway and you don't want to leave
right I thought this party was dead but
actually can you please unblock the
bathroom door if you compare it to like
Captain America Iron Man both of those
movies kind of found themselves right
away the First Avenger the first Iron
Man so it's like Thor kind of took a bit
before we found the version of Thor that
everyone really really loved it's
because he's a god that's it's hard it's
so much harder because it's like
Superman challenge yeah it's very
different like godzilla is constantly
rebooted in different ways because
there's he's so powerful there's so many
different ways you can take him and not
not like ones not necessarily better
than the other they're just very
different well it didn't in some ways
they kind of nerfed him right like they
like made it so that he is more fallible
he don't see they made him stupider
but that also allows like the stoop the
big confident stupid idiot is on my
favorite characters that you can play so
III think that's a really interesting
point though because Thor and a lot of
times is compared to Superman and I know
you said got so up but my point is
Superman I don't know how to support the
well and I think no one's arguing with
you but Superman often has the issue the
rebooting point stands where people are
like look we want to see Lex and then we
basically want to see Zod and then we're
kind of out because there's not a lot
more you can do with Superman I mean
there is but cinematically atomic fire
breath light him up or something yeah
one also from like a giant there are
actively powerful would make a billion
dollars they'd be great so so do you
guys think okay I'm gonna take you on a
different path here though so it sounds
like we're all like yay Thor has a new
trilogy probably or you know let's keep
in mind Chris Evans and Robert Downey
jr. basically okay I think we're done
here and he's you know Chris Hemsworth
is coming from the same time as those
guys is there a chance of Thor four will
be the last four maybe it's possible
that maybe this is the last movie that
has Thor in the title than Thor just
teamed up with other people in their
movies we saw that with like the Asgard
easily galaxies at the end of endgame or
technically Hulk or honk yeah I mean
more Marvel can't do their they can but
at the same time they almost were like
you know what why don't we just eat
remember where else yeah yeah I think
what's really great is the like they
finally found a version of Thor that
seems like it's natural for Chris
Hemsworth to play so he may be done but
maybe he's like I found this new
character that I kind of want to exhaust
you know when I go all the way to the
point so I I would say it's layin fat
you know Tony Stark calls in Point Break
in the first Avengers the Colin Lebowski
it seems like they kind of found a
version of Thor that is in this world of
the Avengers and the way that like they
found a version of cap that really works
for Chris Evans finally they found a
version of Thor and I would be really
surprised if this was the last more I
agree that it's not the last one just
because there
he's handing it so much of it off to
Valkyrie and she's such a she's a
character that I mean I think they're
just gonna set it up to weave into her
whole French becomes female Thor
equivalent comics but exactly that's
really interesting yeah yeah I'm kind of
like of two minds on this because on one
hand you you know that because of their
switching out like cap and Iron Man for
at least you know like for for this next
wave of whatever whatever is happening
you want some kind of like somebody from
the old guard around will probably have
Hulk but you know having Thor around
like is really still like we're still
the Avengers this is still the you know
like just some some one part of the old
team but on the other hand I'm sort of
like well it's got five and where would
you put the five in the word Oh 16 we're
going cubed yeah
the 16 things I like about Thor number
one that's interesting um I think that I
just remembered this theory that
somebody was breaking up that also they
might use it as other way so guardians
galaxy is one way to to get into cosmic
stuff but so is Thor and then if you
have Thor 4 and then if you saw four and
it was made of fire and it was a circle
[Music]
yeah I mean Fantastic Four can can be a
cosmic entity it could be I I actually
saw that theory that they're like oh
maybe that's the way to bring them in
instead of you know like explaining hey
where've you guys been the whole time
it's like oh we were busy doing
something or it came from elsewhere or
something
why not though right yeah I mean I think
it's introduced that might be the next
big temple thing fact if you're watching
this after comic-con you may be really
good that's the
oh you haven't had your birthday fight
yet I think it's a one idea that I
really liked is someone bought of
interest Tower right and that's we saw
that in spider-man far from home one
theory is that the new occupant could be
the Fantastic Four could be the Baxter
build it was a four in the like signage
- oh I didn't see independence because a
lot of work to do but because you're
hater or because of the things they've
already done because of the things
they've already done you know I don't
know I I guess like I I'm also I'm also
of the mindset that I I hope that they
start just in general with soup like
we're at a point where we're rife for
new superheroes as a whole to be
starting so I'm kind of like I'm kind of
like I might mean a Marvel break okay
it's also just where I'm at but also I
mean I even or a break from the the
mainstream ones that we know and we're
but just like it feels like a lot of
permutations now and I kind of want to
like now good like I like the idea of
following Valkyrie for a while or
something just because I'm like I didn't
know that much about her that's cool
yeah yeah where I'm like with fantastic
form like we keep putting them up at
bats imagine like a nerve like Kevin
Feige he's probably like Oh finally I
have a chance to do with yeah I just I
have my take on Kevin Feige that is his
voice now just put a Marvel Studios cap
on there I'm really impressed with all
of these ideas guys I think we saw you
well what is going to be cool let's take
a quick break to thank some sponsors to
bring the show new rockstars road theory
is brought to you by some very nice
sponsors summertime is convention season
for me we got VidCon comic-con con con
all the cons and when I travel I can't
pack a low quality disposable razor but
Perry's has me covered
high-quality travel-friendly shaving
supplies and razors that are only two
bucks a blade a harry's razors as
essential in your suitcase as a bathing
suit or an entire Funko pop collection
you travel with those right they're made
in a German factory to the highest
standards and if you don't like your
shave with a harry's razor just let them
know they'll give you a refund this
summer refresh your wallet and your face
with a Harry's trial set it comes with a
weighted economic handle for an easy
grip a five blade razor with a
lubricating strip and trimmer blade for
a close shave rich lathering shave gel
that will leave you smelling great
and a travel blade cover to keep your
razor dry and easy on the go listeners
of rogue theory can redeem their trial
set at harrys.com slash rock stars make
sure you go to harrys.com slash rock
stars to redeem your offer and thanks so
much for supporting the show by the way
if you want to know how good it looks
when we come back from this break
I used a harry's razor to line up the
top of my beard line today so check that
out and see if you like it all right
back to it welcome back I'm told before
we move on
this is the part where I'm supposed to
not know what yes okay so
stranger things season 3 guys my
favorite thing about it was the ice
cream flavors introduced and at the ice
cream store in the mall that Steve works
at scoops ahoy and this is a napkin
[Applause]
apparently stranger things in epaulettes
did like a cross promotional thing with
Baskin Robbins where you can actually go
and get those flavors USS butterscotch
11 Heaven 11 7 Phillips birthday I
thought we could take a taste test
[Applause]
all right so we got to monetize this
still in our traditional on-brand way so
we're gonna do a breakdown oh great now
it's breakdown breakdown up these I
dance with our tongues flavors so let me
know some miscible details as you go
surprising crunch - which ones which do
we know that the tan one it's a
butterscotch I think which is which is
butter Scott a huge butterscotch person
so for butter yeah you look like a
normal human being not made of
butterscotch person yeah we've come a
long way we still don't have voting
rights but we're doing in the moment
there's a crunch there's like a crunchy
topping thing going on in heaven one
it's at the bones of barb she just like
I said I'll be right back she wasn't
upside down - goodbye - barb bone marrow
though guys while we do this actually I
want to move on to another topic because
I you know what I don't know the
audience it loves us eating ice cream
especially in podcast form yes this does
feel like my best birthday let's go into
a discussion about something that's
happening on our channel and I want to
kind of get the audience involved here
but you guys definitely also weigh in I
want to talk about spoilers because I
feel like you know it's we're in this
kind of precarious place Eric is is more
dealing with it so I've told us before
that
what happen yeah but yeah Eric why don't
you explain kind of the so this is
something that we've been dealing with
for the past like four years of doing
breakdowns will do trailer breakdowns
where we speculate things that might be
in the movie we'll do immediate like
movie reviews and reactions or post
credit scene breakdown so where we have
to kind of do them you know 24 hours
after the movie and what I found is you
know I go through the comments people
tweet at me stuff everyone kind of has
like a different perception of what
constitutes a spoiler in the proper
timing of when you're allowed to talk
about things publicly without a spoiler
warning and what kind of makes it hard
is we try to do spoiler warnings at the
beginning of every video just to kind of
cover our bases but sometimes just so
that people know what conversation we're
talking about we kind of have to put it
something in the thumbnail and in the
title of the video just to kind of to
allow all the people who want to talk
about this stuff to find our video and
every time we do it there's kind of we
get some blowback from people thought
that maybe we talked about it too soon
and the rule of thumb that I've kind of
used in the past that I just kind of got
from just talking with friends about
things when do I think is the proper
amount of time to wait before we talk
about stuff with friends if it's a TV
show like Game of Thrones usually good
people a day one day 24 hours and then
if it's a movie that's really popular
that's easy to find or go to any like
AMC or Cinemark or whatever to go watch
it give people about a week so before
that point cover everything with a
spoiler warning and then after that if
you want to just come out of the gate
and say what we're talking about then
you're probably safe but recently was
spider-man far from home a lot of folks
had some differing opinions let's be
real specific here so what Eric was
mentioning really about being able to
find our videos it's very specific it's
search engine optimization it's SEO so
you need in order to get people to see
your video as the answer to that
question so YouTube is the number two
search engine in the world right Google
is number one and then YouTube so many
people go to YouTube to ask a question
and they might be based on the theory or
something that they've read about it
they've heard about so quick spoiler
actually for spider-man apart from home
when Mysterio dies at the end it seems
like perhaps maybe he didn't
and Eric had some theory about that and
recently the the video that was posted I
had like I think it was Mysterio not
dead
yeah something like Mysterio fake death
I faked I think still alive it was a
picture Mysterio in his dying moments a
so and then how far after the movie had
come out was that video well this is
what the tricky thing is after the u.s.
released it was about two weeks which I
think is well outside the window in my
opinion but two weeks is my window by
the way I think exactly yeah two weeks
to him I think TV I agree it's one day
it's one day if it's if it's something
as as like you know beloved as Game of
Thrones or something where it's like
people get to get there and have parties
for it it's almost like one of those
things where it's like good luck that's
your that's on you to stay it's like a
sports game but that's the thing I would
argue the release of movies like
Avengers in game far from home are
bigger than the Super Bowl more people
watch those things but I think things
that they search for after I think I
think there's a difference I think
there's a big difference actually with
the movies and TV thing because with TV
it's so much more accessible so in a
24-hour period you could find a way to
be like okay well I didn't have time to
watch it last night but here I am on my
phone I can download it yeah exactly cuz
cuz for me personally I love seeing
movies but I I do super all improvisers
and stuff I coach a lot at night and
that sort of thing and I've been working
a lot so getting out to the theater can
be really tough for me yeah so I I think
two weeks is good now I may be but I'm
less sensitive than other people I don't
care about spoilers and that's the thing
I asked like what constitutes a spoiler
also point out Sony did something really
confusing with spider-man far from home
release they released it on a different
day in several countries so what we got
it on July 2nd the UK and a lot of other
countries got it July 5th and they
always release it a week earlier in
countries like China and in in like
Middle East though release it early
because they have they don't have a lot
of piracy laws so if they were to
release it and China on the same day as
the US a lot of Chinese audiences will
just watch the pirated version they
won't make as much
they always release it early to get
ahead of those pirates but I what I ask
of people is like imagine this real
scenario yes some people compare or
someone spoiling something is someone
barging into a room and saying Mysterio
dies right but imagine the flip side of
that imagine you're with a group of
friends and you have all seen this movie
and there's one person there a month
after a movie comes out and says I
actually haven't seen it yet so you have
to all stop talking so you're talking
about our friend Joe let me add the
context of our jobs so for instance on
this Mysterio bideo that is something
that was in the zeitgeist at that moment
I be put it may be another two weeks out
or something are people looking that up
anymore or did they already find the
answer somewhere else because someone
else didn't mind sharing it so now
multiply that times every major property
that we talked about a vendor's endgame
or far from myeloma or Star Wars maybe
or something and then every single thing
that we could talk about that is that
the front of our fans Minds our
subscribers are are buzzing about this
and so are we and we're so eager to talk
about it we can't put out there that we
were talking about it for weeks everyone
else has talked about it and then we
honestly miss out on those views we miss
out on that income honestly and then
that's how our first successes for this
channel where the post credit videos we
did some other stuff that did okay but
when we started sharing hey you just saw
one when we started this what movie I
just come out The Godfather
so the Godfather had this post credit
scene let's explain it to you of what it
is when the die-hard when the movie
comes out the die-hard fans saw it
opening night and they're like man I
really want to know what's gonna what's
gonna happen with
I'm Jackson coming out and inviting them
to the initiative we made we started
making videos that came out like right
that night
those were first minute videos to
consistently hit over a million views
those videos are why we have jobs doing
this those videos are why we have a set
now why were able to pay David's rent
every year so it just created a
situation where we have this business
that kind of requires us to be right on
the cutting edge right in front of the
moment but if we were to wait if we were
to put for instance isblank
really dead and a big question mark
because of search rules we will not rank
for that video no one will find our
video right and what's also frustrating
is like even deeper than like the
economic argument it's frustrating to be
an authority on this stuff and to have
people tweeting at you constantly and
just because of when are you gonna rinse
my our tea of folks are sitting on
waiting specifically what you mean how
people kind of harass you yeah there are
people were like why haven't you made
anything right away I see cyber bullying
which whatever I don't care I'm over
that now but it's like it's you kind of
damned if you do damned if you don't so
I'd rather assume that like if you cared
about this movie that much you would see
it in the opening week I know if you
have a job this is just my opinion but I
kinda want to know what people think
about this if you have a job or a
difficult travel schedule then it kind
of becomes your own burden they're a
playboy you can use to filter your real
fast sorry dude what I was gonna say
about my spoiler rules are for people in
person like like that's that's like for
your friends and stuff like that cuz
Eric doesn't go to your house yes
exactly if you're if you there's
something you really want to see that
you're a big enough fan and then you
don't have the time and you're then then
it's on you to stay offline because
honestly this is the same thing as
sports games but like when people tape
them in the 90s and stuff like that it's
the same thing you saw that is on you so
yeah yeah but the one thing that's tough
though is like if I don't have time I
realize like okay I need to stay off I
need to do things I need to manage where
spoilers are coming from but sometimes
that might mean I can't use Facebook or
you
- at all because they will show you in
the recommended on the sides and it's
like just characters who are at the end
and stuff like that and I can't control
that without literally ending you give
off for a different set of what we call
metadata but thumbnail and title on the
when it's more on the people uploading
is like everybody should have the right
to upload if they have to we don't know
you can definitely go in and mute mute
for certain topics yeah would be great
but I would also say like if you're in
that very and we're getting to a very
very specific situation set of people
who can't see a movie in the opening
week if you're at that point would it
hurt you that much to stay off YouTube
if you have the kind of job where you
have to go on YouTube are you really the
kind of person who can't go see a movie
within the opening week of its release
probably not I think we're getting down
to literally 30 people and they're all
the ones who tweeted at me stones may
break my eye I do not want to show how
little there's less I want to get in on
this I think there also is a bit of like
martyrdom and philosophical argument
really to what we really try to do with
those post credits scene breakdowns and
in the first week when we do make videos
about it we think would a person who had
not seen the movie look at this thumb in
title and know it's a spoiler yeah we've
posted a video stranger things it was
last week's episode of rogue theory
spoiler you haven't finished stranger
things it's just a picture of hopper in
the final episode looking just kind of
emotional and people were like that's a
spoiler that's really had you not seen
stranger things season three you would
not know what that's referring to so a
lot of what we do is kind of thinking
about the the psychology of people
watching or scrolling through YouTube
right now if unless someone else already
told you that this happens at the end
you would not look at our thumb
objectively
yeah exactly so that's another way to
say it but that's what you mean by
martyrdom right because I feel like
that's I don't want a reason to be upset
and they they look at something where
this person is in a category who engages
in this kind of behavior rather than
judging them independently and if I had
just looked at this one actor on its own
would it be a spoiler really the bigger
problem is the broader conversation that
people don't want to be a part of but
don't want to take any responsibility to
extract whatever I mean like we went
right into what we thought about the new
Godzilla film right like right after it
came out and it's it's like the but the
fans that follow that I mean they should
know that we're gonna do that that's
kind of like that but at the same time I
think the best argument is kind of what
we pointed out that they might not have
been seeking out that content it might
have been search engines sure but I do
want to be active in this and I want to
find a way to make things better on us
because I don't I don't I'm disappointed
in you my mom didn't she had a busy week
she was not able to catch spider-man so
I want this to be productive though so I
Eric I want you to share what you think
you you would like to propose the rules
for the channels spoilers and then you
guys in the audience you can be sharing
your thoughts in the in the comments but
also on new rock stars fan con we're
gonna add a question there of just what
you guys think we should do hopefully
you now understand the context of if we
don't talk about the thing and if we
don't put in the thumbnail and in the
title then we do not rank in the search
in our video significantly underperforms
are the brands that we work with get mad
at us our channels start to do worse and
then we're fired you know yeah looking
for some kind of checklist or a legal
standard yes we're saying a simplified
rule that we can just stick to every
time that respects people's schedules
and respects people's viewing habits so
that we can all kind of get along and
then we can go
can reference it and I would like to
create some kind of industry standard
not just for us but for other channels
for other media publications so that we
people can go back and be like no let's
all stick to this and it's just a way to
provide civility that goes both ways
it shouldn't be on you it should be on
YouTube you guys have a problem as it go
harass you to really I mean that's their
search engine that's what it turns up
that's fine I really like that idea of
like let's actually start asking YouTube
you can start tweeting at YouTube and
they do respond we can send some emails
in the meantime until they change
something I am willing to meet in the
middle here a little bit well we might
take a hit based on what our fans ask us
to do but also you know we can only go
so far so good in rock surf and calm let
us know what we should do about our
titles or thumbnails YouTube should have
have like an add-on that lets you do
like the thing that I message lets you
do with invisible ink so that you have
if it's show up in your search results
but it's kind of like you know like a
blurred out for okay let's know you guys
thought and then Eric you'll make but I
do I have four more tubs that I've been
good plasm picture photo from the new
Ghostbusters movie yeah which of course
fin part is what's really interesting
about that too is that he was dressed as
a Ghostbuster in LA but he was mank minh
but in this what a lot of people are
thinking based on this picture and and
we'll put it up in the video version of
this but for the audio listeners what
you're seeing is a some children but
specifically the little girl she's
wearing glasses that basically look like
Egan's glasses
so people are thinking this might be the
family and we're looking at egons wife
and kids Harold Ramis the passed away so
it would be a way to feature him in a
legacy form is routing it through his
family so one do you guys think that's
what they're doing to and is that the
kind of ghost poster sequel you're
excited about well they did say Jason
Reitman kind of talked about we don't
know what the connection is yet between
this family and the original lineup and
he said something weird like the family
doesn't know yet either so if they are
related to Egon it might be like you
know maybe a different name and then
they look up the fact that they were
related yeah there was something like
like maybe he's just died recently and
then they're going through his stuff
forever and they find what is it called
the ghost catcher thing trap yeah yeah
but it's kind of like Jumanji I'm not
afraid to say I'm completely
uninterested in the new stuff yeah why's
that
like I mean first of all the fact that
it's so fast on the heels of the girl
Ghostbusters it feels like it's like
okay guys don't worry we made another we
feel like they came in kind of today
which is also dumb because they
shouldn't end but then also we we've had
some great ghostbusters I just this is
one franchise where I'm like that really
didn't yeah it's like the three amigos
it's like you know it's really to meet
Ghostbusters was always based around
those actors too like that's one of
those things where it's it just doesn't
ring the same like you can reboot a lot
of things and it'll be fine as we've
seen but like certain things were almost
you know they were written for those
actors like yeah written for those
actors actors were involved in the
writing I don't know to me I'm just kind
of like no I'm open to it I'm worried it
would be more of a like here's all the
greatest hits of ghostbusters guys like
in the older ones when I I want if we're
going back I want to see a newer take on
it like that that's that photo they
showed they were like in suburbia and
like kind of had like a smaller town
like feel to it like yeah yeah that's
cool frighteners you know like see yeah
the smaller out of the big city of New
York like maybe even just that change in
setting with like refresh it a bit for
me give it that um that what's the house
the haunted house in New Hampshire on
the Northeast where all the bad things
have happened like kind of that feel
yeah because yeah because if we if we
just do the laps of like you know the
library where they caught that one grade
it'd be fun to see something in the
world of ghostbusters that doesn't
necessarily have to connect to because I
felt like even the one the Melissa
McCarthy Kristen Wiig one felt like it
was still too referential if they had
cameos from Aykroyd and Ernie Hudson
like they all showed up and they were in
the same kind of firehouse like I think
the world have got a world where you
have like exterminators for ghosts is
super fascinating like tell a story in
that world but don't necessarily like
Risha which one is the truest you know
yeah I don't mind blowing out the world
I'm done with that if that's the case
then it's gonna be totally different
then that's fine but yeah like it you
guys hit on it it's like okay so coolest
rule of this world of all time okay no
we're just gonna keep rehashing it
rehashing it instead of like building it
out and making it its own you know other
other world so speaking of that then why
make it ghostbusters right like there's
this so really why make it Jumanji it's
like as a brand yeah everyone like at
least gemologist of the concept of being
trapped in a game or that the game I'll
say why makes the thourough cry but uh
definitely the concept of ghosts and the
genre of comedy that to me feels like an
intersection that you could do in a
million different we wrote a terrible
movie that was
yeah many many jobs that was like a
x-files crossover with Brooklyn
nine-nine I know I just basically had
them I call it the yfiles guys we should
just bring you on just every week just
to do that part
what's a ham guys this is this week
these are questions that we don't know
what the questions say and I don't know
how to read but we're gonna find out
some quick answers for some questions
number one this week is the 20th
anniversary of the release of the Blair
Witch Project what's the most scared
you've ever been in a movie theater were
we in the same here no more no more TV
I'm going to go see paranormal activity
and every time it became night because
it would be good extra space yeah and we
were in that theater and it was it was
like hundreds of people in the theater
and it was like you could hear a pin
drop in one of the moments and then it
just it just said like night two or
something and just heard one guy just go
but that was like like we were yo
haulage and our friends were like they
couldn't sleep alone like that guy
directed midsummer now and there's real
scared Ness in theaters I do this thing
and my therapist is gonna get a kick if
he offers for comfort and I just like I
shut down like emotionally so like
whatever happens like I don't care
because I'm not here you know and take a
little minute black alien in your head
like downstairs
Universal Studios they do the big horror
nights here in LA they followed me
around because they were like somebody's
got to get this girl and I know and I
just don't I just kind of don't spook
but I do remember so it made me go way
way back because I saw Jurassic Park in
the theaters and when she she thinks
samuel l.jackson is there and then the
raptor pops out I remember being like I
wish they brought Sam Jackson back in a
later movie he just doesn't have guys
Kingsman creator uh Mark Miller Miller
predicted on Twitter that Terran
Edgerton will I kind of like this uh
will probably be the next Wolverine so
who is remember that he just did the
Elton John biopic so who can do an
impression of Wolverine singing an Elton
John song and I'll just say that and you
guys just butchered what you could have
been here's a beautiful voice Wolverine
a singing voice Bargo Robbie is said
this week that she's never seen any Star
Wars movie and never will like now
somebody's gonna make her what's yours
she knows where everything's good I
never said where's your what's your
stubborn pop-culture blind-spot
so I'll say it's not necessarily
stubborn but I keep trying Doctor Who
I've tried it so many times and I'd
there's so many different ways you could
go in and watch it and I start to fall
asleep oh man I so what's up for you
guys right now it's gaming like
I don't play a game I had to swear off
games in high school because I was in
advanced academic program but like
everything and you know 2003 on so when
people tweet me stuff do you see the new
Red Dead trailer did he see the yeah I I
have to sit out of it convinced me to
pick it back up blind spots pop
culturally I I have this habit where
whenever something's hot so like like
true detective I always wait for it to
be over because I have such trust issues
with show's ending getting burned oh
yeah so I'm like I'm like like get at me
get every when it's over and see how you
how you feel now you should try Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones speaking up
received a record-breaking 32 Emmy
nominations this week you guys here also
the thing about Gwendoline Christie HBO
did not submit her for Emmy
consideration so she submitted herself
and she got nominated a nice so always
be your own biggest champion yeah who
else in the cast deserves the Emmy the
most I would say Alfie Allen man that
guy like yeah that was great
this music video called Alfie making fun
of us Emilia Clarke I think she I think
she had a lot of I mean I think I think
she heard she did her job to the best
you know you do you have to submit the
one scene where they tried to put a
whole season's worth of story on her
face even that really Mimi thing of like
her fake life her fake smile when she
talks to Sansa you know that was great
like that's a good like that's a great
performance cuz it's a fake smile no I
thought I let you do that's good cause
you're in to do yeah I bet Godzilla got
a Twitter and Instagram cramp that's
what the matrix says Instagram account
this week how does Godzilla slide into
your DMS
I mean he don't slot oh wait on his tail
he slides on the tail rail look guys
look it up got delivery before he slides
on his tail with his feet forward and he
slams into into Megalon
how does he slide in like a city has
offered free beer to any alien that
escapes
area51 no brand jumping on this social
so what what's the best part about
having a drunk alien so happen to et to
the trunk well Elliot
oh yeah ET drinks the beer in the fridge
and I'll write best thing about drunk
alien they misused their tech and they
they blow up the friends that you don't
like I feel like they'd stop lying and
just being like you look you guys are
effed yeah okay well I'm gonna give it
to you straight
yeah to serve human yeah all right guys
the City of West Palm Beach for uh sorry
I forgot to do that the City of West
Palm Beach Florida is planed the baby
shark song on loop to drive homeless
people out of sleeping in their Park
what song would drive you out of a park
what was it there's that Easy Street
song from Walking Dead that they used to
torture Daryl we're on easy street
the writer the song is like I just wrote
that happy kid song used it for torture
at a TV show I mean anything cranberries
like really turns you into a zombie yeah
[Applause]
yeah I have to go like I think there's
like an amount of reggaeton that would
like make me really excited to be at the
park and then I'd make me kill myself
yeah so that was the last question but I
since this is rogue theory as we're
fading out by the way this that's it
subsidy wrote there thank you so much
for going broke with us and our guest
Hayley Mancini where can we find you at
Hayley Mancini or at zero underscore
Godzilla zer oh oh good nice David dong
David dong at David P dong and it's all
just pictures of me in swimsuits loading
up a vos it's in the name is that a
gaming reference I would know everything
Comic Cons so you might already be on
the channel a breakdown of the eight
trailer shot-by-shot
with our good friend marina and then
we're doing some other everything else
that has come out that i already know
about because i didn't tape this before
we learned what big things Marvel I was
released
Philip Melina Apple Maya I never tell
people my name is at the beginning of
this but this is it this is the episode
ends except I just want to talk to you
guys about what we think is really going
on at area 51 these are the rogue
theories I'm gonna have you guys gonna
have a good time thank you so much for
this episode okay but seriously aliens
or dead alien
[Music]